Marion j'imagine que c'est comment votre
nom déjà on vous le demande de moins en
moins quand même non parce que
maintenant on connaît enfin mon nom
Huguette
c'est huguette et les mariée dans la
série à Gérard Hernandez vous savez ce
sont les râleurs ils font ils sont très
antipathiques dans leur immeuble et
c'est vrai que le c'est comment votre
nom déjà maintenant Marion elle
l'entende de moins en moins puisque 7 à
8 millions de gens la voient chaque soir
alors elle publie donc ce livre édition
de l'archipel on va la recevoir
évidemment au préalable j'ai retrouvé
deux documents très intéressants dans
les archives de la télé notamment le
témoignage de Michel Audiard parlant de
Marion puisqu'elle a tourné sous sa
direction et on va commencer par Paul
Meurice quand même le grand Paul Meurice
en 70 Marion Game et sa partenaire dans
un sale égoïste la pièce de Françoise
Dorin voilà ce que Paul Meurice disait
de Marion Game regarder
tout à fait remarquable
et
elle joue avec moi dans le sale égoïste
de Françoise Derain elle elle joue
[Musique]
jeune personne de 19 ans
qui
pour laquelle j'ai une certaine
attirance enfin je ne vais pas vous
raconter la pièce et bien votre place
franchement je crois que je me dirais
bon où j'en suis une de plus une de moi
ça changera pas grand chose
et puis je penserai toujours à votre
place au moins cela elle me comprend et
on sera pas trop de deux pour tenir tête
aux autres et vous êtes les autres vous
aussi non et vous verrez les autres qui
ne s'y tromperont pas
voilà mes deux derniers pensionnaires de
la journée
étrangement dans le film de Michel
Audiard alors là elle joue ma maîtresse
carrément
[Rires]
une camarade
a été propulsée à la fois par Paul et
par 0 parce que ces revenait de tourner
avec elle un film
et Paul joue avec elle au théâtre tous
les soirs et quand je cherchais cette
espèce d'ingénu de fausses ingénue parce
que c'est une menteuse une trucuse et
tout basting ils ont eu tous les deux la
même idée au fond ils m'en ont parlé
tout à fait séparément c'est-à-dire
sérum à Venise c'est je viens de tourner
avec une fille Marion Game c'est elle a
un œil
marrante elle joue vite et puis Paul
m'avait dit tu sais moi je me porte
comme on est quand même parce que après
tout mais tu devrais essayer Marion Game
c'est sûr c'est bien fait c'est du bon
travail
que d'autres qui ont du talent font pour
moi pas mal quand même Paul Meurice
Michel Audiard c'est des bons souvenirs
magnifiques évidemment Marion j'imagine
que c'est comment votre nom déjà on vous
le demande de moins en moins quand même
non parce que maintenant on connaît
enfin mon nom Huguette c'est ça on vous
appelle Huguette on ne m'appellera
jamais Marion Game ça il faut que il
faut que je m'y fasse d'ailleurs on
apprend dans ce livre que c'est pas
votre vrai prénom Marion c'est le prénom
de votre sœur
ou des beautés vous avez pris le prénom
de votre sœur oui parce que René Simon
brutalement m'a demandé quand tu
t'appelles et ça m'est venu mais alors
direct mais j'ai même pas réfléchi et
j'ai pris le nom de ma petite sœur qui
pour pour moi avait à destin que
j'aurais bien aimé avoir votre prénom
c'est Madeleine Madeleine et ça sonne
bien Marion
parce que parce que je vous dis il y
avait dans le destin de ma petite sœur
parce que moi j'ai pas eu l'enfant et
donc j'ai fait un transfert immédiat et
voilà et Marion et ma petite sœur elle a
20 ans de moins que moi et elle a fait
elle a fait quoi comme elle n'est pas
elle n'est pas dans la profession du
tout alors
c'est vous il voulait écrit tout seul
votre bouquin évidemment mais bien écrit
évidemment c'est pas toujours le cas
pour ça que je vous pose la question
Marion c'est tout ce qui vient du cœur
comment voulez-vous quelqu'un l'écrive à
votre place en tout cas je l'ai je l'ai
lu avec beaucoup de plaisir c'est bien
écrit c'est sincère vous racontez qu'au
début ça a pas été facile votre maman a
pas été tendre avec vous quand elle vous
dit tu as vu comment tu es faite avec
tes petites jambes et ton visage
maigrelet arrête de dire des âneries ne
fais pas de théâtre apprends l'asténo
c'est mieux
de ce train voilà et donc dans ce cas-là
il faut prendre sur soi et parce que
oui on prend sur soi et surtout on ne
lâche pas l'affaire dans sa tête voilà
c'était dans mon esprit cause toujours
tu avais charmeuse meberse mais vas-y
j'ai au bout d'un moment je n'écoutais
même plus voilà j'étais sur mon rail des
destiné à faire ce que j'avais envie de
faire mais ça donne de la force aussi
quelque part ça donne une espèce de rage
intérieure
mais à un moment donné vous êtes vous
finissez quand même par être rattrapé
manger
et vous fait glisser dans votre dans
votre dans votre dans votre comment
dirais dans votre attention de dans
votre intention de faire les choses vous
fermez le dossier à un moment donné
c'est ce que j'ai fait quoi avec elle
avec elle et puis vouloir faire du
théâtre
jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à la fin de votre
maman ne vous a jamais félicité pour
vous pour tout ce que faisait rien la
différence totale mais ça les gens le
liront et ces personnel donc ils le
découvriront avec vos mots à vous bien
évidemment alors venez Simon lui il a
décelé en vous une rigolote alors
évidemment vous voulez être vous vouliez
être tragédienne mais c'est à dire que
mon humeur de l'époque où j'étais quand
même j'étais une jeune maman avec les
difficultés que ça ça c'est un comble et
puis et puis bon j'avais pas un destin
facile je travaillais dur j'habitais la
banlieue tout ça était accumulé comme ça
dans ma tête donc j'avais pour rentrer
dans une dans un théâtre enfin dans une
cour de théâtre c'était forcément pour
faire de la tragédie pour faire des
choses graves dans voilà et lui il était
incroyable c'est homme
tout de suite dit va dans le domaine de
la comédie et il a eu raison et je lui
ai fait confiance directement parce que
c'est pour moi la première personne dans
ma tête parce qu'évidemment c'est pas
vrai mais c'est la première personne qui
m'a regardé et qui m'a vu
jusqu'à jusqu'à cet âge-là jusqu'à 25
ans j'avais l'impression que je flottais
un bouchon qui flottait sur la mer mais
qui n'intéressait personne en fait
Jacques Martin épisode Jacques Martin
Marion puisque vous avez partagé quatre
ans de la vie de Jacques Martin alors on
va voir un extrait en fait c'est pas
dans l'ordre chronologique puisque
l'extrait qu'on va voir arrive en 84
c'est la pièce j'y suis j'y reste c'est
vous qui allez moi je me rappelle
j'étais gamin j'étais dans la salle
j'étais venu j'étais venu voir pièces
oui oui je me rappelle très bien c'était
la fête à l'époque mes parents vont
emmener à Paris voir cette pièce avec
Jacques Martin vous étiez sur scène donc
je dis que c'est pas dans l'ordre parce
que en fait c'est des années après
évidemment votre séparation que vous
avez proposé le nom de Jacques Martin la
production de j'y suis j'irai donc la
rencontre et Jacques Martin ou le et la
vie avec lui difficile on en parle juste
après donc lui on a un mot donc lui il
joue un cardinal et vous vous êtes une
une fille nature et spontanée on va dire
voilà c'est ça nature spontanée qui n'a
qu'une qui n'a aucun préjugé par rapport
aux statuts
regardez extrait
[Applaudissements]
l'honneur pour notre maison
ainsi vous voici dans le retour de ce
long séjour en Suisse vous savez que la
conteste ne manquait jamais de me donner
de mon cher nouvelle
je suis ravi de faire votre connaissance
sans Altesse
cette fois-ci ce n'est pas assez
excusez-moi c'est l'émotion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme vous dites
n'a pas marché deux mois à l'affiche et
ça s'est arrêté on avait fait un carton
au théâtre ce soir avec Jacques Morel et
avec Jacques bizarrement ça a moins
fonctionné alors vous résumer à mon avis
toute la situation l'ambiguïté de votre
relation avec Jacques Martin est sur le
fait que ça n'a pas fonctionné vous
dites j'aimais Jacques Martin mais lui
il voulait qu'on l'admire tout à fait il
avait c'est cette quête permanente il
avait envie d'exister et il sentait
comme c'était un homme brillant hyper
intelligent et hypersensible il sentait
bien qu'il n'était pas admis qui n'était
pas du bâtiment entre guillemets il le
sentait confusément et donc il faisait
tous les efforts possibles pour y
arriver parce que son rêve c'est ça qui
est fou Sophie quand on dit Jacques
Martin aujourd'hui c'est un rands star
de la cité du skate
et donc il était frustré de ne pas être
comédien alors que vous sa compagne
aviez des propositions de rôle c'est à
dire qu'à l'époque c'est je l'ai connu
au plus mauvais moment parce que c'est
l'époque où c'était à quel moment de sa
vie sentimentale en 60 je
peut-être quelque chose comme ça et oui
c'est vrai qu'il avait des souffrances
énormes alors qu'il était star mais ça
ne l'intéressait pas d'être star de
cette façon-là et donc du coup là donc
en soufflant son nom à la direction du
Théâtre pour le rôle dans Jésus Giresse
à la fois vous lui donniez le rôle de sa
vie et en même temps comme ça n'a pas
marché ça a été l'effondrement
un joli geste d'amour mais tout à fait
parce que je savais qu'il aimait ça qui
voulait exulter au théâtre donc je lui
dis que c'est un rôle pile pour lui
garder de bonnes relations
pas vraiment non non pas de relation du
tout bon retrouver sur scène tous les
soirs ça doit pas être évident
qu'il pouvait pas se sentir et qu'on
jouer ensemble longtemps vous avez ça
arrive ça n'a rien à voir là c'était la
profession pour moi je cherchais
quelqu'un qui soit connu et qui puisse
rentrer dans le personnage voilà
[Musique]